je m'appelle cédric jalbert je suis là
avec un mot j'ai été élevé à québec
je suis très sportive est toujours prêt
à relever de nouveaux défis
et puis mes débuts à l'école j'ai
toujours démontré de l'intérêt pour
parler devant mes coéquipiers j'ai
beaucoup pratiqué je suis très fier du
résultat de ma présentation
j'ai bien de relever le défi tlx où je
vais vous parler des jeux vidéo
mesdames et messieurs je vous invite à
imaginer notre génération dans le futur
bonjour je vais vous entretenir sur un
sujet qui me tient à coeur
l'impact des jeux vidéo sur l'humain
commençons par les impacts positifs les
jeux vidéo peuvent développer tout ce
qui est visuel l'attention visuelle
ainsi que certains réflexes usuelles on
peut aussi développer notre créativité
avec des jours on ne peut construire des
bâtiments des ponts et des tours comme
myn'club hell illégaux maintenant les
impacts négatifs les jeux vidéo peuvent
entraîner des problèmes de kohler et
d'impulsivité ce qui pourrait nous
empêcher une concentrer longtemps sur un
travail que ce soit un dessin est un
casse tête ou même le travail scolaire
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de la
dépendance chez les jeunes de mon âge si
vous voulez faire le test
les premiers signes de dépendance chez
un enfant se distingue car quel enfant
joue de deux à trois heures par jour
régulièrement pendant la semaine
la dépendance extrême pour atteindre de
très haut niveau en nombre d'heures par
jour
bon maintenant je parlais des
conséquences mais plus précisément les
conséquences physiques psychologiques et
financières que les jeux vidéo ont sur
notre société
commençons par les conséquences
physiques les jeux vidéo peuvent
entraîner les mots des articulations des
doigts des motos des pôles de coûts
ainsi que des problèmes de gestion
maintenant il un impact psychologique et
jeux vidéo peuvent entraîner des
problèmes d'hyperactivité et d'attention
soit le tdah ce qui pourrait nous
empêcher d'être attentifs dans une
conférence et même en classe aupravant
de la mesure a tout enregistré
l'information qui nous est communiquée
par la personne à l'avant aussi la
trisomie de bon niveau peut ainsi un
nombre excessif d'heure de jeu vidéo
pour terminer les conséquences
financières
aujourd'hui une console le jeu peut être
directement relié à une carte de crédit
dans 15 jours pourrait facilement
dépenser tout son budget mensuel
rapidement et même parfois sans s'en
rendre compte
aussi pour les parents on recommande
d'acheter des petites cartes cadeaux
prépayées la console de l'enfant car
quel enfant ne voudrait pas se garer sur
la carte de crédit de ses parents donc
pour conclure les jeux vidéo ça apporte
plein de belles choses comme les
divertir durant une après-midi de plus
par ailleurs une étude aux états unis a
démontré que les jus les enfants jouant
aux jeux vidéo
régulièrement aurait des meilleures
relations amicales donc sa porte l'un
des choses et peut toujours faire
attention à notre nombre d'or car on
peut vite tomber dans la but c'est la
part des conséquences irréversibles sur
nous donc c'était les impacts des jeux
vidéo sur le web par cédric jalbert
l'attendent avant d'applaudir
j'aimerais vous dire quelque chose vous
même vous rappeler quelque chose
la modération a bien meilleur goût merci
et bonne soirée